قال الرئيس جو بايدن إنه
يتوقع تمامًا أن يوافق الكونجرس على تمويل جديد
لأوكرانيا خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع،
وألغى الكونجرس الإنفاق المستقبلي لأوكرانيا
من مشروع قانون لتمويل الحكومة وتجنب
الإغلاق، ووصفت وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية ذلك
بأنه
غير مقبول إذا سمحنا للسلطويين
مثل الرئيس بوتين بالقيام بذلك.  مهما كانوا
يريدون للدول الأخرى ذات السيادة،
فسيتم تمزيق ميثاق الأمم المتحدة بأكمله
وسنعيش في عالم
يمكن أن يحدث فيه هذا النوع من العدوان
على أي حال وفي
أي وقت، الأمر الذي سيكون أكثر تكلفة بكثير
بالنسبة للشعب الأمريكي وأكثر
خطورة بكثير بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة.  أيها الناس،
لا يمكننا تحت أي ظرف من الظروف أن نسمح بمقاطعة
الدعم الأمريكي لأوكرانيا، حلفاؤنا،
خصومنا
والعالم سيراقبون في
هذه الأثناء تقول القوات الأوكرانية إن
الأسلحة القادمة من الولايات المتحدة والدول الغربية الأخرى
ضرورية لنجاحها.
زار فريد بانكين، مذيع سي إن إن،
الخطوط الأمامية للحصول على
نظرة عن قرب، اللواء 80 المحمول جواً في أوكرانيا
يقتحم المواقع الروسية على
الجبهة الشرقية باستخدام أسلحة أمريكية الصنع لمحاولة
إزاحة مكاسب قوات فلاديمير بوتين
التي ربما تكون مستحيلة إذا
قطعت واشنطن
المساعدة العسكرية. هذا الجندي الذي لا يمكننا
تسميته إلا باسم فاسيل يخبرني
لا أعرف ماذا أقول
سيكون الأمر صعبًا، فهو
يقول إن القوات تقول إننا زودنا بأسلحة
مثل مدفع براوننج الرشاش الثقيل الذي
يساعدهم على قلب الأمور لأنهم
أكثر دقة وأكثر موثوقية
وقوة مما يمتلكه الروس.
انظر إلى مدى أهمية المساعدات العسكرية
لأوكرانيا بالنسبة لهذا البلد للبقاء
في القتال، كل شيء بدءًا من البنادق
وحتى أنظمة الصواريخ الأرضية والجوية لمساعدة
أوكرانيا على صد روسيا، أرسلت الولايات المتحدة ما
قيمته أكثر من 45 مليار دولار من
المساعدات الأمنية إلى أوكرانيا منذ غزو
روسيا الكامل.  - عند
الغزو،
اعتبرت كييف أن العديد من الأسلحة ستغير قواعد اللعبة،
مثل أنظمة إطلاق الصواريخ المتعددة
ومركبات برادلي القتالية للمشاة،
والتي تقول كييف إنها أنقذت بالفعل
حياة العديد من
الجنود الأوكرانيين، وفقدان المساعدة الأمريكية، سيكون
كارثيًا، لكن أوكرانيا تعترف بذلك، لكن
مستشار الأمن القومي قال لـCNN  إنه
لا يعتقد أنه سيتم
قطعه، ونحن على ثقة أكبر من أن هذا
لن يحدث. ويقول إنه إذا
كانت الولايات المتحدة دولة مسؤولة عن
العالم الديمقراطي وتولت هذه
المسؤولية، فسيكون ذلك بمثابة فرحة كبيرة
لبوتين وجميع الأنظمة الاستبدادية.  إذا
سحبت الولايات المتحدة المساعدة التي
تقدمها
لنا لكن الكرملين يعتقد أن
واشنطن ستتخلص عاجلاً أم آجلاً من
الإرهاق من
الرعاية العبثية لنظام كييف
في مختلف البلدان بما في ذلك
الولايات المتحدة، كما يقول المتحدث،
وهذا الإرهاق سيؤدي إلى
تفتيت روسيا.
المؤسسة السياسية وزيادة القتال
يقول جنود الفرقة 80 المحمولة جواً
إنهم بحاجة ماسة إلى أسلحة أمريكية لمواصلة
دفع الروس إلى الخلف في الشرق،
لكنهم سيواصلون القتال بدعم
أمريكي أو بدونه،
وليس لديه خيار، كما يقول،
لدينا  للقيام بذلك، شعار لواءنا هو "
لا أحد غيرنا" لـ CNN في شرق
أوكرانيا، ندى بشير، مراسلة CNN، تتابع
التطورات على الهواء مباشرة هذه الساعة من لندن،
وتنضم إلينا الآن، صباح الخير لك يا
NADA، فما هي أهمية
اجتماع يوم الاثنين في كيف خاصة في
ظل حالة عدم اليقين  بشأن التمويل الأمريكي المستمر
لأوكرانيا، أعتقد أن هذا أمر ذو
أهمية كبيرة من حيث
الرمزية هنا خاصة في أعقاب
ذلك القرار الذي اتخذه
الكونجرس الأمريكي، والذي استمعنا إليه بالأمس من
وزير خارجية الاتحاد الأوروبي، سيب باريل، وهو
يتحدث إلى جانب وزير الخارجية الأوكراني
واصفًا هذا الأمر.
كتعبير واضح عن إرادة والتزام
الدول الأعضاء في الاتحاد الأوروبي بمواصلة
دعم أوكرانيا حتى أه في
مواجهة الدعم المتضاءل ربما
من بعض أعضاء الكونجرس الأمريكي، كما
ردد وزير الخارجية الأوكراني ديميتري كبا هذا الشعور الذي
تحدث عنه  أهمية هذا
الاجتماع لوزراء الخارجية
ربما في كلماته أه ليس في حدود الاتحاد الأوروبي
في هذا الوقت ولكن في
حدود الاتحاد الأوروبي في المستقبل بالطبع لا تزال أوكرانيا
تمضي قدمًا على أمل أن
يتم منحها عضوية
الاتحاد الأوروبي كما سمعنا بالأمس أيضًا
من ممثلين آخرين
للاتحاد الأوروبي ووزراء خارجية آخرين
يشاركون في مجلس الشؤون الخارجية هذا
لم يكن من الناحية الفنية
اجتماعًا رسميًا أه
لمجلس الشؤون الخارجية نظرًا لأنه حدث
خارج سيادة الاتحاد الأوروبي لذا لا توجد استنتاجات أه رسمية
أو اتفاقيات ملموسة لكننا
فعلنا  أرى بعض المؤشرات الإيجابية
خاصة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بآمال أوكرانيا في الانضمام إلى الاتحاد الأوروبي.
استمع إلى هذا البيان من
وزير الخارجية الألماني الذي تحدث
أمس مع مجلس خارجية
وزراء خارجية الاتحاد الأوروبي، حيث نأخذ
الاتحاد الأوروبي إلى حيث
ينبض قلب أوروبا.  الأقوى في الوقت الحالي
هنا في كيف هنا في أوكرانيا،
مستقبل أوكرانيا يكمن في الاتحاد الأوروبي في
مجتمع الحرية الخاص بنا وسوف
يمتد قريبًا من لشبونة إلى لوهانسك مع
كل قرية بكل متر
تحرره أوكرانيا بكل متر
تنقذ فيه شعبها أيضًا  يمهد
طريقه إلى
الاتحاد الأوروبي الآن بالإضافة إلى مقترحات
التمويل المستمر والجديد لأوكرانيا
من الاتحاد الأوروبي أه
تحدث رئيس الشؤون الخارجية للاتحاد الأوروبي ي بيل أيضًا
عن هذا الالتزام قائلًا إن هذا كان إلى
حد ما يمكن أن تكون عضوية الاتحاد الأوروبي
أكبر التزام  أن هذه
الدول الأعضاء يمكن أن تقدم لأوكرانيا في هذا
الوقت الحالي،
وفي الوقت نفسه قال وزير الخارجية الأوكراني
إنهم يعتقدون أن هذا يتحرك
في الاتجاه الصحيح وأن
الحكومة الأوكرانية وزعماء الاتحاد الأوروبي
على نفس الصفحة عندما يتعلق الأمر
باحتمالية التوصل إلى اتفاق.  عضوية الاتحاد الأوروبي أن
المفاوضات في رأيه أه من
المحتمل أن تتم قبل
البداية قبل بداية
العام المقبل لذلك بالتأكيد هذا
مؤشر إيجابي من الاتحاد الأوروبي ولكن
بالطبع هناك
متطلبات صارمة معمول بها لأي دولة
تسعى لعضوية الاتحاد الأوروبي أوكرانيا
لن يكون ذلك استثناءً من ذلك، ونحن نعلم
أن الاتحاد الأوروبي قد قدم ما لا يقل عن
سبع توصيات للإصلاحات التي يتعين
القيام بها في أوكرانيا بما في ذلك معالجة
الفساد وغسل الأموال وحريات الصحافة
وحقوق الأقليات، لذا فمن
المؤكد أنه لا يزال هناك الكثير للعمل عليه
ولكن من الواضح أن هناك حاجة إلى المزيد من العمل.  رسالة التزام
رسالة تجديد الدعم من الاتحاد الأوروبي
لأوكرانيا